from the available Pocket Monsters to
the law of paldair here is every
difference between Pokemon scarlet and
violet
the major difference between Scarlets
and violets like every other Mainline
entry in the series is the Pokemon that
you can discover and like in every other
Mainline entry the Pokemon Divergence
that matters most is the legendary
scarlet and violet feature Corydon and
miridon respectively they are both
Dragon type Pokemon but cried on is a
fighting dragon dual type and Mirai Dawn
is an electric dragon duel type both
Pokemon serve as your method of
transportation as you explore paldea and
both utilize the same methods of
traversal however miraidon actually
turns into a motorcycle while Corydon
runs on all fours despite having his own
set of wheels for some reason the only
other new Pokemon that are version
exclusive are amarouj and Sarah ledge
technically what is version exclusive is
not the Pokemon themselves but rather
the items that you use to evolve their
shared pre-evolution Char Cadet Char
Cadet found in both versions of the game
will evolve into amarouge when exposed
to the auspicious armor exclusive to
scarlet and Sarah ledge when exposed to
the malicious armor exclusive to Violet
other than another difference between
the two versions we'll get to later in
the video the rest of the exclusive
Pokemon are all from older Generations
on the Scarlet side you have lavatar
stonjour drifloon oranguru stunky Skrelp
Dano meanwhile Violet features Bagon
iske mischievous persimian Gulpin
clauncher and dreepy in both games the
players are a student attending one of
two different schools nuranha the
Spanish word for orange Academy and
Scarlet and UVA the Spanish word for
grape Academy and violet the two fruits
that Inspire the Academy's names
featured in the logos for the respective
schools for the most part the two
schools are identical with the same
students and teachers in both but there
are some differences the first is the
school color which are reflected in the
clothing the player can wear as well as
the accessories that outfit the picnics
they take their Pokemon on orange for
scarlet and purple for Violet while both
games allow you to pick from four outfit
variations for each of the seasons
spring summer fall and winter the color
schemes for each outfit are respective
of the version you've picked and cannot
be changed you can buy accessories like
shoes and gloves however that do have a
variety of colors to pick from the other
major difference between Naranja and UVA
academies are the contents of the books
within their libraries and as a result
the law of paldea that you can learn
which pertains to the final major
difference between the two games before
you continue with the video I want to
warn you that the final difference
between scarlet and violet pertains to
late and end game content so if you
don't wish to learn about it consider
pausing this video and continuing it
later something that was apparent in the
lead up to scarlet and the violet was
that the games were themed around the
past and the future respectively this
was clear from the designs of the two
legendaries Corydon and miraidon as well
as the clothing of the two version
exclusive professors Sara and turo also
Sada comes from the Spanish word for
past Pasada and Toro comes from the
Spanish word for future futuro those
past and future Aesthetics play into
Paradox forms variants of Pokemon
separate from Regional variants like
palday and Woopa and Tauros with scarlet
and violet having their own exclusives
these Paradox forms are described in the
books of the library in naranha and UVA
academies hence why the content of the
book stiffers depending on the game
you're playing each of the Paradox forms
have a two words name which serves as
the name of the Pokemon itself for
example Scarlet's Paradox form Don fan
is known as great Tusk while Violet's
Paradox form Don fan is called iron
Treads as you can see great Tusk and
iron shreds play into the past and
future Aesthetics of scarlet and violet
respectively great Tusk and iron Treads
are also unique from the other Paradox
forms in two respects the first is that
they're both variations of the Pokemon
Don fan whereas the rest of the Paradox
forms in both games are based on
different Pokemon the other way they
differ as compared to the others is that
they can be discovered as Titan Pokemon
in the path of Legends questline the
rest of the Paradox forms are unlocked
when players reach the end game the rest
of the Paradox forms are as follows in
Scarlet you have scream tail root Bonnet
fluttermane Slither Wing Sandy shocks
and roaring moon in Violet you have I in
a bundle iron hands iron ghoulis iron
moth iron thorns and iron Valiant for
some reason Violet's Paradox forms all
start with the same word and Scarlets
don't and I can't wait to see the theory
videos on why that is the case there are
two additional Paradox forms that are
teased in the games but not actually
featured outside of the books found in
the libraries in Naranja Academy's
Scarlet book a drawing of a paradox form
variant of the legendary suicune is used
as a hypothetical to illustrate a
potential Paradox form and likewise an
Uber Academy's Violet book The
hypothetical Paradox form is a variant
of the legendary cobalian neither is
meant to be an accurate representation
of an actual Paradox form but
considering both the legendaries and the
previous Mainline Pokemon games sword
and shield had DLC content all about
catching the legendary Pokemon this
could be a hint at Future downloadable
content in store for scarlet and violet
foreign